I love your dress thank you so much
fabulous how are yall have youall met I
I have never met you Mr bacon no we
haven't met and she's still holding out
her hand which is the best part Oh I
thought you were just gesturing to me it
it it could have been I could have
played it off as just a gesture I will
say that I we your daughter and I have a
mutual friend oh really Jenna oh yeah
yeah Jenna is a very good friend of mine
and is also a very good friend of your
daughter so I feel like I know no no we
love Jenna I know Jenna too you know Jen
Jenna but oh wait do I know Jenna I
don't know Jenna okay we I could know
Jenna we're have Jenna Onna we're have
Jenna on Jen's gonna love
this so wait you've hosted SNL was it 91
yeah a long time ago yeah yeah how did
you like it it's a long week yeah yeah
it was it was one of the hardest things
I think I've ever had to do I was really
really it was very I found it very very
challenging but I had some had some good
good times and uh I think I my favorite
thing was getting to play uh Vanilla Ice
why not that's good why would that not
be you wrapped in everything uh yeah
kind of super cool I don't remember it
that well but uh Chris Rock at the time
had a had a talk show okay he had a talk
show with with a guy with a giant afro
and and the Vanilla Ice was a guest oh
my go perfect perfect yes yeah are your
parents like so proud of you okay well
yes um my I mean listen I'm first wait
there was a lot with that well yeah well
I mean how much time do I have to be out
here to couch feel comfortable um uh
well I'm first generation
nigerian-american so there's this
expectation that I would go on to be a
doctor it's a thing right that's a big
expect it's a big expectation I think I
did something cooler no offense to the
doctors hey no one no one in my family
expected me to be a doctor yeah right
right but so I but so I wrote a sketch
about it I did it with Daniel Kya a lot
of people related to that one as well
but you know recently I played Jada
pinket Smith on the show and Bad Bunny
was the host and musical guest um my
mother called me the next day to and I
was like oh did you watch the show and
she was like yes uh Bad Bunny has
amazing music and I was like what about
what about what I did what about what
about what about me m how was on Weekend
Update you didn't and she's like oh yeah
I saw that I did see that we have the
same mother but you know what it's cool
it pushes you to really be the best I
love something will get her to laugh
something were your parents like easy on
you or a little hard on you uh my I'm
the youngest of six so oh you had it
easy when I left home I'm not sure my
parents knew I was gone cuz I'm the
youngest I'm the youngest too is it the
three three baby I am the baby as well
yeah three babies we made it guys okay
so how do you get through hard times in
this industry it can be very especially
in SNL because y'all can poke at things
that maybe people don't like sometimes
right right um well I mean before I when
I was pursuing my career before I was on
SNL I had felt with like dealt with a
lot of disappointment and rejection as
an actor you hear a lot of NOS you get
get used to getting rejected it's
actually like the comfort zone right
like Junior High all over again like
adult version of junior high but I I
went on vacation um it wasn't an
expensive vacation like I went to Hawaii
the ticket was $197 that's what I could
afford at the time and I I was like you
know I've been pouring everything I have
into this career and it's like it's just
not working out I need to go somewhere
and I saw tickets for Hawaii for $197 I
was like I do have that much money I'm
going to blow it all I $200 um so I I I
went to Hawaii and I was like you know
what I need to like live a more
well-rounded life and also just Embrace
being alive and being in the ocean makes
me feel this big but in the best way and
then it's calming it's so calming it's
so calming so then I came back to um la
which is where I was living and you know
things continue to be hard but then six
months after that I got on SNL so the
point is take a vac
you two can end up on
SNL that is that is what we're
[Music]
[Applause]
selling thank you guys y'all have a
great night I'm going
home